[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'anciens en
parler sport pour ce cinquième numéro de
la saison on garde la recette qui fait
la force de cette émission il y aura
comme d'habitude des analyses des débats
et des duels avec nos chroniqueurs ils
sont trois autour de cette table
aujourd'hui la présentation on commence
à ma droite mesdames et messieurs c'est
un champion du monde de cyclisme sur
piste master's et il est sur votre
plateau et nulle part ailleurs nous
avons d'ailleurs verrouiller son contrat
de chroniqueurs le pistard de vélizy 78
elle dut jarrier est avec nous on a fait
un contrat va faire un contrat long
terme
amoral men vous avez très bien prêt prêt
pour l'émission comme la pollution
on va découvrir les sujets au fur et à
mesure passe de l'autre côté à musique
qui nous vient lui aussi de versailles
il est aujourd'hui à mâcon trama
contente de cette émission on le
surnomme dans cette émission le
gladiateur car il aime combattre dans
l'arène de ce talk e pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous 8
c'est sa vie bonjour salut les copains
comment allez-vous puis ça va très bien
vous montez en puissance au fur et oui
c'est ça c'est ce même ration physique
cet été et maintenant va bien et mentale
est de plus en plus de plus en plus
partant pour ces joutes verbales on a
hâte de voir ça en social on termine de
l'autre côté un musique c'est peut-être
le meilleur d'entre nous quand on
regarde cette émission on veut
absolument le voir ses fans sont de plus
en plus nombreux notre super
chroniqueurs spécialistes rugby coach
jean miss ex entraîneur de plaisir est
avec nous pendant une heure vous nous
faites encore l'honneur de venir sur ce
plateau
besson en vigueur comment allez-vous
tréviers quelle forme je suis content
d'être là on envoie des lettres ont
regardé mission pour vous même pas pour
les autres chroniqueurs mais pas pour
moi pour vous alors c'est bien je suis
je suis ravi un message pour eux avais
je leur fais la bise on pense tous
le message est passé alors avant de
passer au titre de l'émission commence
par du football le tirage au sort du 8e
tour de la coupe de france de football a
eu lieu la semaine dernière et
versailles qualifié après sa victoire 3
2 face à sainte marie à la réunion a été
épargné le dernier représentant
yvelinois se déplacera chez un club de
nationale 3 vire ce tour est le dernier
avant l'entrée en lice des clubs de
ligue 1 en 32e de finale là une dernière
verse s est arrêtée au 8e tour de la
compétition contre lens une réaction sur
ce tirage national 3 pierre chevalier
plutôt favorable c'est toujours mieux
qu'un tirage de gros même si une équipe
de nationale 3 donc c'est une équipe de
son de sons vidéos d'un nouveau d'une
autre d'un autre district de l'autre
région donc évidemment un tirage plutôt
plutôt favorable maintenant reste à
savoir s'il ya des disparités niveau
entre les différentes régions
mais si on regarde à peu près et c'est à
peu près le même le même niveau avant
l'arrivée des pros et et la réception de
lens l'année dernière c'est quand même
un tirage un petit peu plus un petit peu
plus facile et je dirais va pas falloir
faut pas rater le coche de peut-être
pouvoir tirer un plus gros au prochain
tour là il ya une petite pression
supplémentaire
et alors manque de bol voilà il se
déplace donc ça aurait été bien de
pouvoir recevoir et d'être d'être à
perseigne ouvrons donc dommage mais mais
voilà c'est une belle motivation pour se
dire on peut aller chercher une une
belle équipe lors du but lors du
prochain tour donc on va leur souhaiter
de pouvoir de pouvoir avoir cette
confrontation et puis ben prendre du
plaisir au maximum de gens vous êtes
d'accord
ils ont un coup à jouer versailles a
réuni heureux et surtout pas qu'ils
fassent à des anneaux il ya cette eau se
sur ce match là
mais si nos frontières les prix des
licences pause et d'expliquer alors d'où
je viens
bien sûr c'est un match tout à fait à
leur portée
j'ai moi j'y crois vous préférez quoi
jean tu me ton contre lens ou contre
contre vire par exemple l'analyse c'est
tombé contre lens de la piste est une
grosse équipe
grosse affiche là la fille je fais un
petit peu moins rêver quand même
aberrant même civile est un très bon
club
quand même et de ses animaux donc on
n'attire pas on n'attire pas du monde
avec une équipe du même niveau
c'est le match les matchs de tous les
dimanches et joue des équipes de
nationale 3 donc lorsque matière est
vraiment l'année dernière rencontre
contre lens il y avait beaucoup de monde
ça les lieux un peu parce que c'était
une affiche là ça sera à l'extérieur
quand même hein je précise voilà mais
bon ben là là c'est normal ou fait venir
une affiche forcément il y avait
quelques du cube
thürler la tribune des ultras versailles
alors au prochain tour ils peuvent
tomber on va pas leur porter la poisse
au prochain tour il pourrait tomber
contre une ligue 1 est ce que vous
voulez qu'ils tombent tout de suite
contre une ligue 1 entre deuxième en 32e
de finale en janvier différents centres
sportifs et spectacles si c'est si ces
sportifs ils auront sur le papier
beaucoup moins de chance donc il faut
pas leur souhaiter en terme de spectacle
et de et de se mesurer à ce qui se fait
de mieux
surtout si c'est à versailles mais a
priori ça sa bouche après sur ces tours
là donc je dirais plutôt sportivement
éviter les gros tout de suite pour aller
espérer aller le plus loin possible
ça peut les motiver ou pas d'avoir un
club de ligue 1 au prochain tour je leur
souhaite d'avoir un club de ligue 1 au
prochain tour et de pouvoir justement
délocaliser dans un stade plus grand et
de vivre l'expérience de pouvoir jouer
devant
je sais pas cinq dix ou quinze mille
personnes c'est quelque chose de juste
phénoménal canton quand on est quand on
est sportif etc
je pense quand un club de national
s'inscrit sur une coupe de france
l'objectif c'est justement d'espérer
pouvoir montrer ni ya un moment ou un
autre
donc moi je leur souhaite de pouvoir
vivre et puis il ya tellement une
surprise dans les dents dans les coupes
de france et je pense que si on doit
rencontrer un club de ligue 1 dans une
coupe de france il vaut mieux le prendre
au mois de janvier
justement sur une période où parfois ils
ont un peu plus de mal juste après la
très renommée que les clubs amateurs ont
aussi mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être le moment où il ya le plus de
chance de pouvoir passer ce second
second gros poisson lors de ce mois de
janvier voilà donc avant de penser à ce
tour il faut gagner de l'argent alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de la transat jacques
vabre et de louis burton le skipper a
terminé huitième de la course nous font
également un coup de projecteur sur le
handicap dans le sport des journées de
sensibilisation sont organisées pendant
une semaine à plaisir mais avant de
développer ces thèmes on va parler à
rugby
du rugby dans cette page résultats
plaisir avait mis tous les ingrédients
pour réussir à remporter la victoire
contre chartres ce dimanche 24 novembre
mais une deuxième mi temps de folie n'a
pas suffi lors de la 9e journée de
fédérale 2 après un premier acte dominé
par charte 17 à 10 les rugbymans plaisir
oise se sont ressaisis en deuxième
période devant leur public qu'ils
arrivent à inscrire deux essais dont un
à deux minutes de la fin du match pour
passer devant 24 à 17 mais en quelques
minutes leurs espoirs de victoire
s'effondre charte marque un essai de
pénalité puis arrive à inscrire une
pénalité
quelques secondes plus tard score final
27 à 24 pour les visiteurs des faits de
jeu effectivement des des coups de pieds
qu'on envoie directement en touche des
choses non maîtrisée des quelques
touches aussi con conquête qu'on n'a pas
de trois ballons qui nous manque
énormément forcément à 24 partout au
look de pénalité pour gagner
effectivement bon bah ui de la m ouais
ça s'est joué à deux trois faits de jeu
sur la fin
et malheureusement ça tourne ça tourne
contre nous encore il votre réaction
suite à ce scénario
pierre chevalier
rageant rageant parce qu'à ce niveau là
les moindre faux-pas notamment à déminer
à domicile ne pardonne pas donc le
scénario de 202 matches semble assez
assez rocambolesques et là ça semble ça
semble dire que plaisir et sur un petit
peu un petit peu plus dans le dur par
rapport aux saisons précédentes où ils
ont réussi à correctement figure et
surtout se maintenir en fédérale 2 là
ils sont obligés de revoir un petit peu
leurs ambitions à la baisse il ya
peut-être des faits deux groupes et
autres qui qui interviennent là d'hommes
en tout cas la salle et ça va les
obliger à revoir un petit peu le déroulé
de la saison et leur ambition genre sur
le scénario
abbas remettra joue un rôle majeur sur
cette fin de match mais je n'ai pas fait
juge n'est pas réglé mais je ne perçois
en tout cas le l'intérieur serbe
nommé pas ne met pas la défaite sur le
dos de l'arbitré donc je ne pense moi je
pense qu'il ya mauvaise gestion de fin
de match certainement sur l'essai marqué
à à moins de deux minutes de la fin
lorsqu'il vit passe de 1 à 24 17 et de
mon avis une très très mauvaise gestion
sur la réception puisqu'il marque
il prenait s'est pas fixé et voilà et
donc il ya ça puis l'entraîneur l'a très
bien très bien analysé les coups de pied
directement touche donc des détails sur
des matchs serrés comme ça c'est
toujours les détails sur les détails qui
font la différence
mais pour revenir à plaisir cette année
disons ils ont pris ils ont pris
maintenant le niveau de la fédérale 2
sauf que sauf que cette année il faut
reconnaître que la poule dans laquelle
ils sont il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
petites équipes
contrairement à la poule d'un côté vous
avez vous avez une équipe comme homos
par exemple qui a pas gagné un match
donc il ya des clubs qui sont qui sont
assez faibles dans notre poule là dans
cette poule là pour le plaisir et n'a
pas y en a pas il ya eu des clubs très
fort comme marque à maroeuil ou ou alors
ou alors des clubs qui se tiennent et
c'est pour ça qu'on me voit on voit
plaisir qui à mon avis a le même niveau
que l'an dernier
sauf qu'ils ont dans une poule qui sont
beaucoup plus serré et j'ai pour
poursuivre leurs résultats je veux
qu'ils se réfèrent deux belles
performances qui sont allés faire match
nul à gennevilliers ils sont allés
gagner à sarcelles alors que sarcelles
est la première équipe à avoir battu
marc à maroeuil qui est quasiment
intouchable dans cette poule qui logo de
la poule sarcelles d'évacuer plaisir est
allé gagner à sarcelles donc si l'on
fait deux belles performances à
l'extérieur
malheureusement à la maison mais ils
font le faux pas contre chartres
et puis ils font notre faux pas aussi à
domicile contre une autre équipe qui
était pas qui était pas d
et un cadeau à un cador de la poule on
voit justement le classement à l'écran
ils sont 10e actuellement sur 12 équipes
engagées
voilà donc malheureusement ils vont ils
vont ils vont y vont combattre à mon
avis jusqu'à la fin de la saison pour
pour pour lyon il se doit de maintenir
mais quand on voit orléans dernier
orléans on sait que j'ai eu des gros
problèmes de début de saison par rapport
à leur stade par rapport à leurs joueurs
je pense pas qu'en deuxième partie de
saison en d1 va rester dernier donc ça
va être très très chaud et très très
serré d'être compliqué pour plaisir ça
va être compliqué mais je pense qu'ils
en sont conscients et et moi je sais que
cette poule est très très très compliqué
avant de parler de reparler du
classement juste un petit mot est ce que
c'est une faute professionnelle d'avoir
perdu
c'est pas une faute non peut dire faites
pour déchaînait déjà c'est pas des
professionnels à la première chose est
sûre tous donc première chose c'est pas
des professionnels donc on peut pas leur
leur appliquer cette c'est maintenant
oui apprendre à gérer une minute trente
c'est quelque chose qui doit ce qui doit
se faire et est bien certainement que
comme disait jean un problème de
réception à l'engagement ça c'est on
supporte pas la pression à la main il
faut pas que je me rate est bon se cache
peut-être que dans les livres hors jeu
je pense pas que c'est le niveau la caf
la phrase mais quand on voit laisser aux
images quand on m'a laissé entre les
entre les perches de 2,2 du joueur de
plaisir là je jeu parce qu'ils ont mis
en place un de laval début les joueurs
dire que là on nous révéler ce qui est
déterminés on me dit que le match était
terminé et dans leur tête marqué à 1
minute 30 le match se termine et bien
sûr mais sauf que sauf que ça la fin du
bal qu'on paie l orchestre
voilà peut-être que le bronze au cerveau
les c4 tu en voilà aux images champion
du monde voilà quatorze mois 4dans voit
la réaction des joueurs qui est normal
puisque cette année c'est il reste une
minute trente
mais là on se dit je pense que dans
leurs têtes sont ni salle et on a gagné
mais il se fait marcher dessus la
connexion des confrontations
oui ça c'est sûr une des causes
impatient parce que sur cet essai dans
leur tête je pense qu'il dit pour
essayer le match était terminé et
malheureusement il n'était pas d'amis
s'est fait piétiner à pierre chevalier a
été sanctionné le 7 cartons jaunes à
baisser en route et ça le kg m2 chacun
thon rouge par leurs excuses et même
bien avant
c'est plus du stamping l'aï fait non c
est au moins il y retourne au moins
quatre fois par an il appréhende donc
après cette défaite plaisir se retrouve
désormais donc à la 10e place du
classement de fédérale 2 avec seulement
deux victoires au compteur on disait
précédemment
l'équipe se retrouve donc en danger pour
la suite de la saison l'écoutent la
réaction du coach forcément on va on va
on va pas mettre la charrue avant les
boeufs et voilà on va être humble encore
une fois travail etc humilité mais voilà
on va tout faire pour se maintenir
encore une fois cette année je vais
quand même vous poser la question sur
cette thématique les jours de plaisirs
ont-ils raté le coche après cette
défaite
oui ou non vous votez oui oui un petit
duel entre pierre et jean gens vont
commencer juste pour faire du président
le coche quand on perd un match à la
maison
bon c'est vrai que c'est
quatorze matches à la maison mais mes
moyens mais nos gâteaux perdre votre
char maison c'est une contre performance
après raté le coche on va dire que pour
moi ça élimine malheureusement les
belles performances qu'ils ont pu faire
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure à
sarcelles et à je lui dis donc que
perdre un match comme ça qui était
largement à leur portée à domicile
baisse à annuler cette grande ses
grandes mains ses grandes performances
qu'ils ont fait voilà mais après bon
raté le coche c'est un grand mot la
saison est loin d'être terminée
on n'est même pas la trêve donc ils ont
le temps qu'un de refaire d'euros de se
refaire la cerise
l'entraîneur l'a dit ils vont reprendre
les matches et que beaucoup d'humilité
et il ya il n'y a pas de réseau que les
performances qu'ils ont pu faire en
cette première partie de saison et les
réalités repas en deuxième partie
pierre chevalier dans une poule de
fédérale comme ça que ce soit la
scélérate 2 en l'occurrence celle
retrouve même fédéral une quand on joue
comme c'est le cas de plaisir depuis
trois saisons plutôt la deuxième partie
de la deuxième partie de tableau
même s'il avait annoncé que cette saison
ils visaient plutôt la première partie
voir les places qualificatives
il faut tout faire pour gagner à la
maison était axé ses lacets là où le ou
la différence se fait en bas de
classement
c'est à dire tous gagné donc raté le
coche oui à partir du moment où ils
perdent un match à la maison autant
autant dans une poule aussi aussi dense
comme le comme le rappelait jean et
deuxièmement un match qui était
clairement à leur portée parce que même
s'ils avaient été menés à la mi temps
derrière son revenu ils auraient pu le
ils auraient pu le ils auraient pu
l'emporter
donc oui il rate le coche parce qu'ils
perdent un match à la maison et celui là
malgré les victoires à l'extérieur qui a
pu avoir avant les faits étaient
automatiquement annulés donc donc c'est
cédé points des points laissés en route
juste je mettrais comme jean un petit
bémol c'est qu'ils prennent quand on est
le bonus défensif et ce point là à la
fin de l'année contre le re peut-être
pas contre orléans ça c'est vrai ou
contre les équipes qui se battent pour
pas descendre pourra faire la différence
puis vous a convaincu
et oui la vie de pierre c'était david
pierre et je reste sur la vie de pierre
et moi je vais plus loin c'est que en
effet ils ont raté le coche et les
quatre points qui l'ont perdue risque
enfin de roubaix ce droit ça fait 3 2 et
3 la wii trois fois qu'ils ont perdus
risquent de peser dans la balance à la
fin mais peut-être que le point qu'ils
ont pris les sauvera aussi au final mai
dernier sera d'ailleurs question sur
plaisir ça fait trois ans qu'ils sont
dans cette division est ce que il
fallait c'était pas la saison il fallait
passer un palier genre ont dit soit 6
coloris derrière que devant
logiquement oui oui on dit souvent ce
sont des cycles de trois ans ne trois
saisons c'est vrai que à la troisième
saison si on se projette sur un projet à
court terme
c'est généralement autour de trois
saisons et c'est vrai il est vrai que la
marche avait été franchie un montant
infini râle 2 et c'est le quoi je parle
et donc ensuite le projet d'après du
club
logiquement s'inscrit dans ce projet
c'était comme l'a dit pyatt à l'heure
c'était le figurer dans la première
partie de la poule puisque ça fait de
ces autres qui sont qui se battent pour
pas décemment
donc forcément si ça évolue c'est que ça
évolue dans le bon sens et qu'on regarde
toujours devant et on arrête le se
battre pour pour ne pas ne pas descendre
donc effectivement le projet pour
l'instant je ne connais pas ils ont pas
été soulevé une année par le fait qu'il
ait pas une équipe qui descend
plaisir souvent ça peut être vraiment un
palier c'est par rapport à la vie de
groupe qui vivent bien ou mal mais c'est
si c'est le même groupe depuis trois
saisons avec peu de changements au
boudin au bout d'un certain moment sur
la sur les saisons qui se suivent et
peut-être se ressemblent ça devient
lassant de jouer le bas de tableau et
pour ne pas descendre et prend de
prendre des danses ou perdre on perd à
l'extérieur ou à la maison un peu
régulièrement ça peut commencer à user
un groupe donc c'est là où sur une
troisième saison
peut-être avec des apports extérieurs ou
un changement de méthode c'est là où il
faut il faut inverser la tendance est
plutôt passée dans la première partie de
tableau
jean va complètement partir sur la
fiction imaginez que vous êtes
entraîneur de plaisir j'ai connu ça
qu'est ce que vous diriez à vos joueurs
maintenant à c'est très compliqué parce
que je pense que les discours sur le
monde et je ne sais pas ce que ce ce que
peut dire sébastien aux joueurs mais je
pense que c'est pas une question de
discours mais comme comme l'a très bien
dit fier le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que il ya une certaine lassitude qui
doit s'installer et lorsque il y a est
il le temps passe et qu'il n'y a pas de
résultat fait qui a pas de résultats
probants
c'est à dire qu'il puisse leur faire
franchir cette marche ce palier pour
aller sur la première partie de la poule
du championnat
c'est compliqué c'est très compliqué
parce que soit soit le message ne passe
plus soit mais on est en atteignent
les cadres en atteint le mât le maximum
de ce qui pouvait amener à ce groupe
mais après c'est pas leur faute
je dis pas qu'ils sont pas bons ou quoi
que ce soit c'est simplement que
abandonné cessé de ce sport avec général
et particulièrement sport collectif mais
abandonné il qu'un gars ce cas le
message ne passe plus qu'elle ça passe
plus on n'en est pas là encore il faut
je pense que le point ce sera plus une
fin de saison quoi donc pour l'instant
moi je reste je reste qu'un positif pour
eux et moi je leur dirai je leur dirai
bien il faut gagner c'est que de la
fiction bien sûr je le rappelle parler
de voile louis burton originaire de
rambouillet a réussi à terminer le 11
novembre dernier la transat jacques
vabre avec son coéquiper davy beaudart
ils ont relié le havre au brésil à bord
de son bureau vallée 214 jours cinquante
et une minutes et 43 secondes un temps
qui leur permet de finir huitième chez
les imoca on écoute la réaction de
beaverton par téléphone la transat s'est
bien passé d'un point de vue sportif
puisque en fait on a terminé la course
on a pu 1 sur des des grands run de
vitesse entre le les açores à peu près
puis l'arrivée on a pu remonter cinq
bateaux donc voilà ça et effectivement
la question sur ce thème
êtes vous déçu par son classement 8e je
le rappelle non non personne n'est déçu
quand je fais un petit duel entre pierre
et eliane pierre vacances et je n'avais
pas forcément déçu déçu
non pas forcément déçu parce que c'est
je crois que c'était pas la gagne même
si on sport c'est toujours la base mais
la guerre n'était pas forcément
l'objectif 3 qui je crois qu'il partait
pour pour tester tester le bateau pour
d'autres courses et et tester tester ses
aptitudes toujours présente
notamment si je me trompe pas sur le
vendée globe donc on pouvait peut-être
attendre un petit peu mieux d'un duo
comme celui-là et d'un skipper
expérimenté que comme lui mais n'est pas
forcément déçu parce que parce que là la
course en elle-même lui a permis de leur
green yachts et quelques quelques places
après le ccc dans sa préparation et dans
les objectifs initiaux que je n'y vois
pas de déception manifeste
yann bien sûr parce que les objectifs
c'était c'était beau dire quand même
hein c'était une place entre 3 et 5 de
mémoire voilà dans les top 5 et voilà et
donc 6 pts 3 ils ont des événements et
donc du coup ben on est plutôt top3 plus
là donc quand on parle de 5,3 plus non
mais je trouve que c'est on est loin de
l'objectif de départ on sait c'est pour
ça que c'est décevant quoi maintenant
voilà les circonstances de course il ya
plein de clins d'éléments qui font que
ben c'est la place à l'arrivée ça reste
comme il le dit la satisfaction c'est
que le bateau n'est pas cassée n'y a pas
de pas de bobos non rien de rien rien à
réparer pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
s'inscrire dans la préparation pour le
vendée globe qui partira l'année
prochaine
c'est un an pas juste après voilà ce qu
elle est donc
donc voilà c'est juste dommage de pas se
dire on a pu pousser le bateau plus un
sou et je pense d'ailleurs en fait il
n'y a pas de casse mais parce qu'ils
n'ont pas être demandée aux bateaux plus
que ce qu'il a donné là et alors qu'ils
auraient peut-être pu lui demander plus
et aller chercher ils ont mis le frein à
main voilà un genre qui vous a convaincu
alors moi je vous émerveiller suscité de
la vie dehors j'étais déçu papa pas
spécialement par location j'étais déçu
pour lui ce que lui espéré espérer un
podium et tom le top le top 5 c'est à
fait ça je m'en souviens aussi et c'est
pour ça que je suis que je suis déçu
parce que je pense pas qu'il ait qui est
qu'ils aient freiné le bateau parce
qu'il était là justement pour le tester
et donc lots que j'ai le contre
performance en quoi c'est une contre
performance
et après il ya des facteurs extérieurs
que sur les maîtrise pas ses voiles
c'est c'est le propre de de ce sport là
c'est malheureusement il ya des factures
facteurs naturels canton lesquels on ne
peut rien me cantonner le meilleur tiko
si je veux dire il a commencé la course
en prenons très au large vers l'ouest
pour repiquer et contrairement à des
concurrents qui ont pris plus tôt vers
les açores justement en longeant les
côtes et du grès partir du moment où il
a été dans la botte dans la bonne dans
la mode raid besoin de se dire que le
bateau est rapide
donc en effet il ya eu un mauvais choix
de la le départ il a testé montrent
qu'ils ont appris ils ont appris et 5 ou
des conférences et je pense que ses
choix comme ça de route sept coups de
poker parce que s'ils baissent ici là
les conditions climatiques pour
peut-être que peut-être que ça lui
aurait son choix camion il est il était
peut-être là il était peut-être c'est un
coup de poker sajoo poker souvent c'est
souvent ce qui se passe dans ces courses
comme le choix aussi des déroutes faux
pas de rencontre et de containers non
plus
pierre chevalier est ce que le fait
qu'il ait navigué avec davy beaudart qui
n'avaient pas forcément une grosse
expérience sur une transat jacques vabre
a pu jouer ou pas oui parce que c'est un
duo oui sauf que sauf que c'est un an
ils sont soit ses copains son copain
d'arabie son copain dans la vie donc
c'est pour une dvi bodart l'habitude de
faire des courses mais plus plus réduite
il a déloqué de quelques rendez vous en
mai surface qui lie la puce
il a plus privilégié le côté humain et
le côté agréable de partir avec un
poteau tour du monde donc qu'il est de
traverser l'atlantique que que de
prendre vraiment un skipper expérimenté
qui puisse qui puisse l'aider qui puisse
l'aider à remporter la course encore une
fois je pense que c'est là aussi est ce
qui revient mon absence des déceptions
c'est une différente objectif car s'il
avait voulu peut-être vraiment vraiment
mettre toutes les chances de son côté
pour aller chercher ce podium voire
mieux
là il aura peut-être il aurait peut-être
fait le choix sportif d'un et le choix
de la compétence là c'est le côté humain
pour aller tester de tester le bateau en
condition se mettre lui dans les
conditions du vendée globe
à terme donc donc je pense me casser une
question d' objectif est et de ce
côté-là lui n'a pas dû être déçu sa
diète assez une traversée à céret
agréable je récapitule le palmarès de
louis burton sur une transat jacques
vabre il a fini 9e sur celle de 2015
cinquième en 2013 7e en 2011 et donc
8ème cet américain
alors dès la bourse termine en tout cas
louis burton est déjà sur son prochain
objectif le vendée globe 2020 on en
parlait justement les courses où le
sportif yves binois a de grandes
ambitions en écoute
c'est sûr que ça ça reste l'objectif
faire mieux qu'en 2007 ça c'est sûr donc
7e pour faire mieux qu'un club fin que
c'est pas loin et puis bon finir quand
il ya on sait que sur le vendée globe
même avec des bateaux qui sont plus en
plus fiables malheureusement il ya entre
les casses mécaniques et qu'assume aide
extérieure en général la moitié qui
n'existe pas à terminer donc
essayez tout faire pour paraître dans
cela donc beaucoup travaillé sur la
fiabilité
bien sûr il peut faire quelque chose sur
ce vendée globe 2020 pas lui souhaiter
et il a le bateau pour ça c'est déjà une
première à une première chose donc bah
ça de bateaux de banque populaire qui a
remporté le dernier vendée globe
justement avec armel le cléac'h il avait
terminé le tour du monde en 74 jours
alors que louis burton avait terminé en
87 jours son tour du monde avec bureau
valait 1
il avait terminé donc 7e donc ça veut
dire qu'on aimerait bien mettre l année
prochaine il mettra 13 jours de moins le
problème c'est que le vent de ce bateau
qui a gagné devant des blogs il y à
bientôt quatre ans parce que le vendée
globe c'est tous les quatre ans la
technologie enfin les technologies ont
énormément évolué ces dernières années
et donc les nouveaux bateaux qui
s'engagent sur ce sur ce type
d'événement
il y aura un gros décalage de deux
technologies et donc du coup les chronos
farrell et il est temps de détente
navigation vont encore une fois des
cendres très fortement
donc la seule chose qu'on lui souhaiter
c'est de réussir à faire 4 74 jours
voilà plutôt 87
comme il a pu le faire et déjà s'il
arrive avec le même bateau à faire le
même temps que l'année qu'il ya et il ya
quatre ans ce sera déjà très très bien
et puis après comme il le dit c'est la
chance de parents contre un container
c'est la chance de pas avoir de casse de
pas voir baril et donc de pouvoir
rallier l'arrivée c'est déjà une
performance quand on fait le vendée
globe
là il faut en dehors du du de l'objectif
de places faut de la première chose
c'est comme ça d'être à l'arrivée de
jean vous êtes d'accord avec avec amy
il aura un bon bateau me l'aura pas
forcément le meilleur bateau
forcément je pense qu'il ya là tout un
tout dit sur ça il est il s'est dit
c'est forcément le bateau qui fait
valoir tôt le bateau c'est quand même un
fouillis fêtards des chances égales mais
il ya une part de chance mais c'est
quand même c'est quand même pas la
majeure partie c'est comme si je file
voir le bateau le bateau y fait pour
beaucoup et la technologie à a évolué
donc les bateaux ont être encore plus
rapide qu'ils ne l'étaient et donc
forcément je pense que ça va être
compliqué quand même pour lui de le
gagner de gagner d'ailleurs il année une
année conserve plus que lui il visait
quand même le top 5
donc il parle pas de gagner le vendée
globe il vise le top 5
en tout cas gagné à bateaux qu'à gagner
il ya quatre ans quatre ans après il
peut viser le top 5 parce qu'il connaît
les adversaires et les adversaires c'est
pas ça va suffire à lui-même qui sera
pas dans le top 3 de style du top 5 4 en
quatre ans plus tard tu as aucune
garantie qu'un bateau vainqueur puisse
rééditer avec avec quatre années de
l'année quatre années d'évolutions
technologiques et d'entraînement aussi
des skippers c'est du recyclage alors
c'est du recyclage mais son challenge
c'est d'égaler le chrono de 10 à 4 ans
et voir peut-être d'essayer de le battre
mais
c'est une performance personnelle et
c'est un objectif qui doit se fixer
mais après au delà ça va être compliqué
de pouvoir de pouvoir viser enfin on
voit bien des évolutions des évolutions
qui est assez et c'est magnifique
parce que ça reste très beau bateau bien
sûr au dernier l'euro valait 1 - k
l'euro valait deux noms celui qui a
remplacé le banque populaire il vous a
plu la fin sur cette thématique ont duré
en tout cas bon courage à louis burton
pour ce vendée globe on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler d'ici là on passe
maintenant notre page coup de projecteur
dans cette page coup de projecteur nous
allons parler d'une thématique nous
tient particulièrement à coeur chétive
et 78 sur ce plateau le sport et le
handicap pour sensibiliser les enfants
sur cette thématique la ville de plaisir
organise à partir de ce lundi 25
novembre jusqu'à ce vendredi 29 novembre
des activités pour les enfants des
primaires et des collégiens teste
plusieurs sports comme le basket le
tennis de table ou la gymnastique en
situation de handicap
c'est la quatrième édition de cette
initiative on écoute l'un des
responsables de l'activité
on essaie de toucher un peu toutes les
familles le handicap physique donc là
vous avez les fauteuils roulants
vous avez aussi le handicap visuel vous
avez la surdité
on essaie de représenter un petit peu
toutes les familles et les enfants
puissent se projeter un petit peu dans
toutes ces situations
la base est la même depuis le début on
change les activités au fur à mesure et
on améliore d'année en année et ce n'est
pas forcément si simple de se glisser
dans la peau d'un sportif handicapé
comme l'ont découvert ces jeunes qui ont
testé le basket fauteuil c'est assez
compliqué déjà de se diriger de faire
des dribbles et de marquer surtout c'est
faux quand même réussir parce qu'on les
bars comme on est dans un fauteuil donc
pour tirer faut s'entraîner bah on voit
que c'est difficile et qu'ils veulent
quand même quand même mieux faire vous
avez déjà testé le basket fauteuil
autour de cette table
oui le rugby fauteuil au rugby fauteuil
quelles sont les difficultés on a
l'habitude de manier un fauteuil tout
simplement c'est et que donc on se
retrouve dans une situation qui est
toute nouvelle
donc il ya beaucoup de paramètres à
gérer
et puis ben quand vous faites ce type
d'initiation juste en face de vous vous
avez des traits qui eux font tout et
n'importe quoi avec leurs fauteuils sont
très capables de rouler sur une seule
roue et ils vont à une vitesse qui est
juste phénoménale et ben vous retrouver
comme un con tout simplement c'est vous
bah ouais c'est une vraie leçon de vie
et moi et enfin j'ai été pilote sur un
championnat du monde d'un athlète
malvoyants et basse et d une expérience
géniale quoi j'ai j'ai kiffé faire faire
ce faire ce championnat du monde
c'était en 2018 donc savourer sans merci
merci c'est tout récent et d'un résultat
qui était anecdotique mais année un
résultat quand même et c'est vrai que
pour moi c'était une belle une belle
expérience et c'est vrai que j'encourage
tout le monde dans quel que soit le
sport parce que le football il existe
aussi pour les pour les joueurs aveugle
et c'est vrai que ils développent des
choses d'essence qu'ils sont et c'est
beau de les voir faire c'est ça reste
des beaux moments
j'ai vu des athlètes man show donc
sambre à faire du vélo donc à tout à
chacun se dire je vais et je vais faire
du vélo sans les mains willem est donc
là ils sont appareillés pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir prendre le départ et ce qui
est vraiment impressionnant c'est
derrière de voir les performances qui
sont réalisés moi je me souviens d'un à
tête russe sambre à l'avoir vu sur une
poursuite avoir vu ses chronos ensuite
je suis incapable de faire le deuxième
kilomètre que lui que me faisait le
premier kilomètre c'était juste sur un
kilomètre
il me mettait trois secondes et voilà ce
sont des athlètes et des athlètes
complets et des vrais des très belles
préparations et et puis ce sont des gens
qui prennent du plaisir quand ils sont
dans leur dans la discipline le rugby
fauteuil pour vous des fauteuils
principale différence est que ça se joue
à l'intérieur par rapport à un terrain
en herbe extérieur c'est toute une toute
une affaire et c'est rien de le dire de
coordination globale nous n'ont
évidemment pas l'habitude d'avoir à
gérer autre chose que notre corps les
jambes les la tête et la tête et les
bras mais c'est c'est une désormais
après une affaire de volonté
ils sont effectivement capables de
manoeuvrer le fauteuil assez rapidement
d'un d'un bras de fer la passe de
l'autre alors que nous il nous faut il
nous faut beaucoup plus de temps pour
appréhender
s'acclimater avec le fauteuil il ya un
autre support aussi que je n'ai pas pu
pas pratiqué puisque c'est pas mon carré
auquel j'ai eu j'ai eu la chance et je
dirais vraiment la chance d'assister
c'est le golf le handigolf avec la tous
types de tous types de handicaps
effectivement membres supérieurs membres
inférieurs il ya notamment un champion
un champion qui équatorien je parle de
au départ mais qui est maintenant qu'il
faut qu'ils jouent en france depuis un
grand nombre d'années qui s'appelle
manuel de los santos qui joue sur une
jambe
et justement cette affaire de
coordination quand on est golfeur de
voir de voir une telle intel a dans l'
équilibre sur le sur une seule jambe
c'est phénoménal il a aucun problème de
puissance sur le haut du corps et il a
juste cette coordination et 7,7 flexion
autour de sa seule jambe valide qui
force le respect qui a et qui impose à
une immense admiration pour ces pour ses
champions là c'est très bien que la
ville de plaisir puisse s'engager pour
sensibiliser tout le monde aux
handicapés surtout en fait 80 qui le
font ça c'est fantastique de leur part
et c'est ça permet surtout surtout
d'ouvrir peut-être un maximum de gymnase
de terrain et d'activités aux enfants et
aux jeunes et moins jeunes handicapés
qui peut et qui puisse du coup
participer on participe à tous les
sports justement est-ce qu'on
sensibilise assez les enfants aux
handicaps sportif jean
seulement nos soldats font des enfants
moi je suis admiratif devant le sport ce
lundi sport on en a parlé par rapport à
travers les exemples qu'ils ont donnée
mais mais c'est pas du tout du tout du
tout médiatisé et c'est pas que les
enfants qu'on sensibilise pas parce que
si de temps en temps et dieu sait si on
a des dd tu parlais du rugby du rugby
fauteuil qu'il est que l'équipe
nationale a de très bons résultats dont
on ne parle absolument jamais jamais
jamais donc 1-0 médiatisation sur les
résultats de deux de ses disciplines
handisport et c'est regrettable parce
que on ne peut être qu'admiratif par
rapport à ce qui est réalisé et quand
nous on fait du sport et quand on a du
mal alors imaginez un peu dans certaines
conditions le pire ce qui se plaignent
pas et qui sommes très heureux il ya
guère que dans les sports olympiques qui
ont fait que ça que ça peut ça peut
donner lieu au moins tous les quatre ans
à une mise sous projecteurs avec les
jeux paralympiques
on voit souvent ça soit en 2021 voilà
c'est ce qu'il faut espérer c'est quand
il veut et dans les gagnants parce que
c'est beaucoup de cas en athlé et mais
surtout les sports paralympiques et là
au moins tous les quatre ans on met un
coup de projecteur sur ces sur ce sport
et surtout sur c'est sur ces volonté et
ses capacités c'est et ses capacités
mentales à toute épreuve
on le voit depuis tout à l'heure des
athlètes départ des athlètes handisport
yvelinois gagne des trophées sont en
tête d'affiche dans beaucoup de
compétition est ce que viennent du
jarrier est ce que ces athlètes la com -
radius par exemple devrait rencontrer
encore un peu plus les jeunes pour les
sensibiliser au handicap
est-ce que message ne passerait pas
mieux justement avec un athlète
paralympique par exemple comme il faut
sensibiliser les jeunes à tous c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes la fin
la vie elle et elle est trop belle pour
pour dans notre pays et donc il faut les
y folle sans oublier à tous c'est à dire
que voilà faut arrêter de se plaindre au
quotidien parce que ben il ya pire
ailleurs il ya moins bien même en france
et donc il faut se sortir les doigts du
cul quand on a envie de quand on a envie
de quelque chose eh bien il faut aller
chercher tout seul il faut pas attendre
que on vous donne c'est pas comme ça que
là c'est pas comme ça que la vie la vie
fonctionne maintenant pour le handicap
moi je ayant eu d une saison avec avec
les avec le milieu handisport il ya
quand même de gros gros problème c'est à
dire que dans l'est dans les structures
pour les handicapés on encourage à faire
du sport mais on n'encourage pas à faire
de la compétition et c'est un vrai vrai
problème et alors c'est vrai dans le
milieu du handicap mais de toute façon
c'est vrai dans tout le lait tous les
domaines dire qu'il faut faire du sport
tout le monde le dit tout le monde en
parle mais les gens veulent bien faire
une activité physique mais ne veulent
pas faire de compétition et la
compétition c'est quand même ça qui va
vous donner une envie de vous dépasser
au quotidien et de vous dépasser pour le
sport mais de vous dépasser aussi dans
votre travail dans votre vie dans votre
vie de tous les jours et moi je le dis
je suis l'homme que je suis aujourd'hui
parce que j'ai eu cette cette envie de
me dépasser et j'ai appris à me dépasser
dans le sport et donc après j'ai fait le
transfert dans d'autres dans d'autres
domaines domaines du quotidien
j'ai vraiment il faut arrêter de penser
que la compétition est un est mauvais
pour l'éternité
alors dit et tout le monde a maintenant
vous faites une activité sportive fait
de la compétition vous allez apprendre
vous allez grandir vous allez gagner en
confiance en vous vous allez apprendre
on ne gagne pas ou ne perd pas on gagne
ou on gagne oui mais on apprend on ne
perd pas on apprend genlis dernière
question est ce que ces athlètes
yvelinois doivent aller au collège
en primaire pour pour justement
transmettre leur leur vécu rajhi ce qui
est originaire du vésinet yoann qui
eurent la bulle tennisman pied de
voisins voisins-le-bretonneux bien sûr
vais sur sept jours et plus et toujours
plus de ce que comme je disais comme ils
ne sont malheureusement pas très peu
médiatisé
abc a eu à faire la démarche d'aller
d'aller aux devants pour pour se faire
connaître
puis pour pour montrer dès le jeune âge
aux enfants qu eluana dieu ça gagner une
médaille de bronze paralympiques au 1500
mètres en athlétisme en 2016 ah oui
aouidat on a des médaillés on a là il ya
un an mais il n'est pas français
au tir sportif pistorius est fils
médaille d'or au pied au désir au tir
attention c'est un peu limite alors à
passer maintenant à une nouvelle
thématique les yvelines ont accueilli la
semaine dernière deux stars jérôme le
banner l'ancien kickboxer et l'ancien
nageur alain bernard on commence par
jérôme le banner ce samedi à 23 novembre
le sportif est venue donner un cours
destiné aux pratiquants de sports de
combats d'arts martiaux au gymnase de la
malle me donne l'ancien athlète d'un
mètre quatre-vingt-dix pour cent vingt
kilos environ a donné un cours de deux
heures objectif partager son expérience
moi je mange en recul face la façon dont
- mabri mois on a pris beaucoup
chaussures jaunes après plusieurs formes
pur style et enfin j'ai fait mon style
jlb
et j'essaie de leur inculquer ce à dire
qu avec eux le bagage qu'ils ont on
essaie de voir d'autres petits horizons
mais c'est la même chose mais avec
quelques différences frapper sans et
frapper détruire genre de réaction pour
la chute
j'adorais la méthode de banner gr de la
chute j'adore la chute il n'a pas fait
il fait pas rire les capteurs lui et il
doit bouger
sortez vous devrez alors l'événement
trucks a regroupé des dizaines de
participants venus du secteur mais
également de la france et de l'étranger
je souhaite aussi corbas c'est une idole
c'est super super bowl pour moi un
exemple à suivre donc
la quarantaine passée est toujours là
quand j'ai 54 ans ok c'est un exemple
assuré maléfique eu la chance de
pratiquer avec quelqu'un d'aussi célèbre
d'aussi technique est aussi reconnue et
principalement l'humilité parce que
cette personne là il faut savoir que
c'est un exemple d'humilité direction
par rapport à la venue de le banner
pierre chevalier il est passé il n'est
pas son coup d'essai il me semble qu'on
était déjà venu à vil prix allant de
sénou doit hélas vite revenu de saison
donc je me souviens que ça avait déjà
été écourtée vais régulièrement au
niveau de france voire en france c'est
dans dans son art avec c'est avec ces
mots avec ça avec sa pratique et son
expérience faire partager faire partager
au plus grand nombre
c'est une très très bonne chose on en
parlait juste à l'instant pour la partie
handicap et partage d'expériences là on
est on est dans le monde des plus tôt
des champions et de ceux qui sont titrés
qu'ils sachent justement venir à la
rencontre des sportifs amateurs des
sportifs du dimanche même de ceux qui le
de ceux qui le suit depuis des années
qui sont peut-être beaucoup plus
aguerris c'est une très bonne chose ça
participe justement à l'expansion et à
l'aura de ce sport de ce sport là et
plus il ya depuis à des athlètes ou
d'anciens d'athlètes qui viennent qui
viennent au contact
mieux c'est mais c'est pour tous les
sports et pour le développement du sport
en général vient du guerrier vous qui
êtes un grand fan de jérôme le banner
votre réaction du grand fan non je
n'aime pas les sports de combat donc non
pas grand fan mais c'est vrai que murray
a présenté une session avec huit grandes
en grand respect pour ceux pour ce
champion j'ai le souvenir d'un combat où
il s'était cassé draps et il a continué
et donc voilà c'est un mental à toute
épreuve dire que le maître il sait qu'il
a un gros problème mais il y va quand
même
et vous ça vous a plu mais oui parce que
ben on n'est pas la fermeture doit
peut-être parlé pendant ce court oui
c'est paris c'est de toute façon c'est
c'est un des films marquants de sa
carrière ce gérant de manière ce ce
combat moi qui ne suis pas fan des
sports de combat je le sais et j'ai
jamais entendu parler et je m'en
souviens donc ses fans qui étaient là
bien sûr qu'il se souvienne de 2 de ceux
de cet événement il avait été champion
du monde par la suite c'est voilà donc
c'est un très très grand champion c'est
un très très grand sportif parce que on
ne devient pas manger respect pour tous
les sportifs de haut niveau qui qui
arrive à un très haut niveau
parce que ben a cédé de la très grosse
discipline au quotidien l'entraînement
et puis ben tout est mis en place pour
aller obtenir le meilleur père là mais
le meilleur est jo dan hamer performance
c'est la nourriture c'est des sacrifices
tout au long tout au long de l'année
pour certains objectifs
donc voilà il faut pas faut vraiment le
savoir
c'est tous ces grands sportifs ont des
ondes et vicky qui ressemble pas aux
autres
une autre star cette fois ci la natation
était à poissy alain bernard est venu ce
mercredi 20 novembre à la piscine mignot
dans le cadre du master class le double
médaillé olympique aux jo s'est glissé
dans la peau d'un entraîneur le temps
d'un après midi
ça me plaît parce que voilà j'ai des
anecdotes aussi dans mon passé qui m'ont
permis de rencontrer des champions je
m'en souviens ça m'a marqué je m'en suis
servi et voilà ça peut avoir un impact
sur eux que ce soit quelque chose
d'assez quantifiable dans le sport ou
dans leur vie voilà c'est ont contribuer
à leur épanouissement on aura rempli
notre mission
cette treizième dates de la tournée
française d'alain bernard et était
destiné aux enfants du secteur âgés de 9
à 17 ans les jeunes sportifs ont pu se
prêter au jeu des questions réponses et
nager sous le regard de cet ancien
professionnel qui a stoppé sa carrière
en 2012
c'est très important pour moi parce que
on a quand même une grosse mine une
grande histoire des réalisations mondial
s'est
c'est incroyable je trouve ces inédits
on pourrait dire que ça comme ça on voit
champions
et puis enfin c'est un honneur pour nous
on n'a jamais vu un champion olympique
comme ça en rêve
valero
impressionnant une super expérience pour
ces jeunes bien ouais mais clairement
clairement une super expérience là on
est même un cran au dessus de jérôme le
banner parce qu'on a on a un double
médaillé olympique dont là là on a
vraiment du champion du champion de chez
champions il ya une chose qui me marque
sur ma sur ces 2,2 champions et sur ces
deux reportages c'est ce qui a changé
depuis quelques années c'est
l'exposition médiatique de l'après sport
de l'après sport de haut niveau
tu parlais du parler des sportifs de
haut niveau maintenant ils sont ils sont
tellement exposé que il le banner il a
fait du cinéma alain bernard il a fait
la télé réalité ils sont sollicités
maintenant tout le temps donc de les
voir revenir aux sources au sport
amateur
après des années de profit de de sport
professionnel et surtout après peut-être
après après des années de distraction il
faut bien gérer la carrière d'après
d'après haut niveau mais je trouvais ça
me fait 200 et oui si je trouve ça je
trouve que ça ça revient plus aux
sources du sport il peut faire
évidemment ce qu'ils veulent pour pour
gérer leur après carrière mais qu'il
n'oublie pas d'où ils viennent ce qu'il
représente désormais et d'aller au
contact des plus jeunes c'est c'est une
très belle transmission gens d'ailleurs
il a il a eu une phrase qui résume un
peu lui se souvient jeunes à avoir
rencontré des champions et ça l'a marqué
donc ça se trouve c'est profond et c'est
super pour un grand sportif qui était
allé mais là c'est magnifique de pouvoir
donner ce que lui ont ce qu'on lui a
déjà donné que de retranscrire de donner
aux jeunes et de peut-être de 2,2
que certains mais il l'a dit le dit
lui-même aussi ça va peut-être en faire
un fer à me faire exploser suscité
suscité quelques navets le futur alain
bernard peut-être essayer de poissy et
il le fait la justice là il le dit et
moi je dis que c'est super c'est super
parce que au moins il n'oublie pas il
n'oublie pas d'où il vient ce qu'il a
fait ce qui est ce qu'on lui a apporté
maintenant il la porte aux autres et aux
offenses et ses magnifiques vient du
jarret oui j'ai participé à ce type
d'événement alors c'était pour le roller
et paraissent ce sont des décomptes ce
sont des champions et multiples
champions du monde qui vous donnent des
cours vous avez la proximité avec eux
pendant toute une journée
ben les messages passent pas de la même
manière votre coach du quotidien peut
vous avoir dit la même chose comme ça
vient de la bouche d'un champion
champion du monde champion le médaillé
olympique et ben je suis sûr que la
résonance pour l'enfant n'est pas n'est
pas la même et donc bien sûr que sérieux
à l'entraînement juste derrière ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'ils vont avoir un boost
pendant une période
ça va aller ça valait alors elle va les
gagner et là quelques-uns pour qui ça va
durer dix jours et là d'autres pour qui
ça va durer six mois
et il y en a d'autres pour qui ça va
durer deux ans et mais voilà il va y
avoir quelque chose qui va être apportée
par cette journée où ils ont pu
rencontrer alain bernard ça aura pas le
même impact pour tout l'est pour tous
les enfants
mais c'est ça qui va faire que ben
peut-être oui plus tard on aura un alain
bernard qui viendra de la piscine de
poissy de poissy milieu de poissy alors
on va passer maintenant notre dernière
thématique notre page débats focus
maintenant sur le championnat de
régionale 2 de football
musique ludovic gauthier n'est plus le
coach de l'équipe de trace depuis fin
octobre et a été remplacé par richard
azer dit son nom vous dit peut-être
quelque chose c'était l'entraîneur de
l'ess trappe la saison dernière lors de
la montée pour nous parler de ce come
back nous avons reçu le joueur de
trappes
toufik ben saada sur le plateau du 7-8
sport oui une surprise une surprise
parce qu'on sait ce qu on se croisait on
était régulièrement téléphone ensemble
mais jamais il avait évoqué cette
possibilité mais je pense que lui plus
que nous encore et ans est un amoureux
tra est un amoureux de ce club et que je
pense que c'était le premier malheureux
de voir la situation dans laquelle on se
trouve est alors je pense que il a
décidé tout naturellement de reprendre
le flambeau
est-ce que c'est surprenant de le voir
revenir au club de trappes
après l'avoir quittée il ya tout juste
six mois ce qu'il a l'air surpris à
toufik ben salah ce qui est surprenant
c'est de devoir le début de saison de
trappes qui n'étaient pas forcément très
mauvais puisqu'on parlait plutôt resté
plutôt vers le plus bas du classement
mais on nous parle on parlait de deux 2
matchs qui faisait basculer ou pas de la
saison bon après est-ce que c'était le
mal était à ce point à ce pan profond
qu'il faille changer d'entraîneur c'est
plus ça qui est surprenant après que que
ce soit un amoureux un amoureux du club
et de la ville qui a acquis en viennent
là c'est peut-être un surprenant théo
surprend donc à un ancien coach s'arrête
quatre cinq six mois et puis revient
mais non mais ça s'est déjà vu c'est
tout simplement parce que le club devant
la situation dans laquelle ils se
trouvaient a dû certainement à l'étape à
la porte puis dire voilà écoute
reviennent ou filer un coup de main mois
donc on va dire qu'il joue les pompiers
de service
il le fait à travers le club qu'il aime
bien la ville qu'il aime bien donc ça
s'est déjà vu c'est déjà vu dans notre
discipline et et maintes et maintes fois
quoi donc là et quand il faut on aime
plein on n'est même pas là milieu au
milieu de la saison
il ya un gros malaise au sein du club
allait trouver un entraîneur aujourd'hui
il y en a plus puisqu'ils sont tous des
clubs
donc on essaie trouvé la solution de
repli la plus favorable pour le club on
se dit tiens
l'ancien entraîneur il fait plus rien
bon ben nessib ou pas après il était
parti pour raisons professionnelles à la
fin de la saison il fait monter le club
en régionale 2 et c'est pour ça que tu
vas venir pour le club et il a quitté
ses fonctions pour raisons
professionnelles et là il a pu
s'arranger pour revenir au club quand il
a vu la civi les affaires on dit souvent
mon arrondissement raisons
professionnelles pour produire les
vannetais pas le reste si les revenus
c'est qu'il a le teint et qui peut le
faire tant mieux pour le club et en
espérant que ça va rebooster rebooster
le groupe et que tu rappes va va
retrouver le chemin de la victoire du
nigeria ça vous surprend
ce retour ce come back la question est
difficile dit elle puisqu'elle est à
l'intervenant que l'on ne connaît pas
maintenant
bref même des jours n'était pas au
courant j'ai bien entendu en même temps
d'une interview et bien sûr que ben oui
c'est du coup si les joueurs eux qu'ils
sont
qui sont les premiers intéressés étaient
ont eu la surprise oui bien sûr que
thomas on va considérer ça comme une
comme une surprise
maintenant voilà il était parti parce
que il pour raisons professionnelles
alors on ne connaît pas mais peut-être
que maintenant que ça fait six mois
qu'il est dans son nouveau poste ou
danser voilà le changement qu'il a eu il
s'aperçoit que finalement bien il aurait
la capacité de pouvoir gérer le club
peut-être que c'est lui qui est venu en
disant ben finalement le tchad a mis
dehors le challenge de r2 ça va vraiment
intéressés on n'a pas les tenants et les
aboutissants artistes surtout dire que
l'entraîneur qui a démarré la saison qui
justement est ce que six petits mois est
justement la question sur ce thème
est-ce que tu rappes fait le bon choix
en faisant revenir hicham et redit plus
tôt et après avoir viré du devis de
gauthier est ce que tu n'as pas fait de
bons choix
j'étais bien placé que maire il s'est
classé 10e sur toutes les 112 maintenant
le bon choix on saura n'en viendra la
fin elle est bien sûr genre moi je suis
en train de vous êtes en scène tout
simplement parce que le bol choix alors
c'est pas une question de bon le choix
c'est une question que là il est au pied
du mur avant la vie lorsque lorsqu'un
club fait ça change c'est son entraîneur
d'un coup comme ça du jour au lendemain
même pas la moitié de la saison
c'est simplement pour faire un
électrochoc au groupe effet
psychologique voilà et pourrait pour
pour pour pour faire un électrochoc et
faire repartir le groupe
en plus avec un entraîneur qui était
quand même apprécié et qui avait des
résultats donc le le le bureau le bureau
directeur du club où le président on n'a
pas les tenants et aboutissants mais
bref quelqu'un est certainement le
président après la décision et cette
décision là elle est prise pour encore
une fois fait un électrochoc et repartir
sur une dynamique positive
tout simplement c'est ce que ce que font
la plupart des cas ce que ce sont
peut-être les joueurs qui ont demandé
peut-être alors autant de déchets
interdits même s'il n'avait pas l'air au
courant je dirais qu section elle change
comme une rafale de critiques sur notion
de talent
le 10 juin dont celui là sur les phases
de jeu notamment offensives apparemment
de l'équipe
ludovic gauthier voulait mettre en place
un jeu de transition un jeu plutôt je
voulais dire de possession alors que
trap est habitué à un jeu de transition
et il n'a pas forcément les jours pour
on l'a vu au niveau des résultats et les
joueurs ont critiqué ce choix est ce que
finalement les gens n'ont pas la base
6,7 cette raison qu'on ignore cette
fameuse raisons professionnelles
conduisant 600 élus n'ont pas mais mais
après tout on ne change pas une équipe
qui gagne
elle était elle était elle était montée
est montée en régionale 2 avec avec les
honneurs une première donc on va on va
rechercher celui qui avait su trouver
les ingrédients d'une bonne recette pour
monter et se maintenir a priori le
nouvel entraîneur qui a été qui a été
choisi pour remplacer au pied levé cet
entraîneur titré derrière là bas il n'a
pas dû su trouver les bons ingrédients
et j'ai un nouveau coach hicham et redit
ses victoires et un nul en deux matches
c'est pas encore la révolution née mais
c'est déjà et c'est déjà nuls 2 défaites
j'aime mieux que de défaites et donc et
donc oui si on reprend les bonnes
recettes
on arrive déjà à la fin de cette
émission va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui je vous
propose de terminer par une phrase de
robert marchand le cycliste détenteur de
plusieurs records de longévité dont deux
qu'il avait réalisé au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines a
fêté ses 108 ans ce 26 novembre
nous allons reprendre une de ses phrases
je ne suis pas un phénomène
je suis un type comme tout le monde
seulement j'ai usé de tout mais je n'ai
abusé de rien à bientôt sur tv 70
[Musique]